My favorite activity!
3, 2 ,1
(Peter the intern dies a lot.)
Blackmagic, they make DaVinci Resolve, and DaVinci is a free colorgrading program
It works really well. One of the guys there saw our Star Wars drone video,
"You guys need some sick cameras for putting on drones"
They have sent us a Blackmagic Micro Cinema Camera, basically a little action camera.
So, think like of a GoPro but a lot more cinematic.
[Plastic ripped to shreds. To shreds, you say?]
Ooh, look at how tiny this guy is.
Wow, that's really cool, actually.
Dude, this is like maximum efficiency of technology right here.
Sweet, I can't wait to fire this up. Let's get some T E S T   I M A G E S !
A few months ago, I was opening up the door to our studio, and Wren was on the other side,
And he fired a Nerf gun at me, and as that dart came flying towards my face, I thought,
"I could do this. I could be a total badass."
And I reached up and I snatched that Nerf dart out of the air before it hit me in the eye.
I'm wondering, is that something really easy to do, or is it actually almost impossible?
Do we all have secret ninja skills?
We're going to up on the roof, and we're all going to shoot Nerf guns at each other's faces,
and see if we have the ability to snatch Nerf darts out of the air.
Let's go.
[Cool transition, bro]
Alright. Try to shoot me in the face!
[Hearty chuckles]
My pleasure!
[A very weak shot]
THIS GUN SUCKS!
[gun gets smashed on ground]
3, 2, 1!
None of the darts even hit me, so I wouldn't have even had to catch them.
I was just being efficient with my use of energy.
A pro would have caught them.
3, 2, 1!
The fuck is that?!
What the hell, dude?
3, 2, 1!
OOOOOAAAAAAAHHHHHHHAOHOHOHAOHOHWHOHOHOHOWWOHAOHHAHOWHOAHOWHAAOOOOH
What was that?!
Ooooohhwoooooaahhhhwoooaaaaahhh!
[bite off head of dart, chewed up, and spit out]
I didn't even have to move my hand; I just had to close it.
No.
Pvwwwhhhhzuuuuu, schwing!
3, 2, 1!
Oh, you went right for my face!
Hehe, I did that on purpose.
Arrows? Ain't no thang.
3, 2, 1!
Wooaaah!
Twice in a row!
One!
I'm going for four for four!
That one was a fastball. Schwooo!
They call three-four, for short. Thirty four.
I have been tasked with putting together this Blackmagic Micro Cinema Camera.
I'm putting it together, because Niko asked me to.
I think I just needed to have a job sent to me.
Oh, there's the light.
Woah, you can see the sensor.
We need to get a monitor for this.
Okay.
There it goes.
I say we put a lens on the camera.
This is an adapter.
It will line up the red dots.
There we go.
This is hilarious.
This is called an Israeli arm.
You always do things the most efficient way.
I'm gonna grab an arrow like this as it flies by.
3, 2, 1!
YEEEAAAAHH-woo-AAAAAAHHHH-woo!
So, Wren here is back from Vietnam finally.
Wow, so everyone's caught an arrow. Yep.
I have to not fail here.
Just walking along, minding my own business, but suddenly Wren pops out. Wren!
Wren's dead.
Alright. Ok, I'm going to shoot you, Niko.
Alright, let's do this!